move on
time for marketing move on first up A.G
Merrick Garland has appointed U.S
attorney David Weiss at special counsel
and the hunter Biden probe it's not that
kind of probe
wise has been investigating Hunter since
2019 but the new distinction grants him
the authority to prosecute federal
crimes and any Federal Judicial District
arising from his investigation none of
those words make sense to me Charlie you
know all day today uh I've heard this is
good no this is bad the one word is it's
a sham I keep hearing people say this is
a sham is it a sham probably
um why is it a sham uh well I don't look
any investigation is good obviously
whether or not uh this particular
prosecutor is gonna who tried to hatch a
sweetheart deal with Hunter Biden in the
first place right that was a complete
that was a complete sham it it does
certainly raise suspicions that this is
going to be another sham that said what
to me the most interesting thing about
it is the political aspect of it
obviously because
um this is the most politicized doj in
history and the fact that the bid
Administration that Joe Biden who
completely runs the doj as a junta of
his Junta the fact that that he is
feeling the pressure to do that means
this story politically speaking is
blowing up and becoming very uh is
hurting him politically and to me that
is a good thing it means that that
um that P that it's breaking through the
the media effort to they tried it's
about I mean I mean but this could be
the way of I guess like loosening the
screws and letting the tension ease but
not really you can only put so many
fingers in the dike before it just watch
you know we don't have to get sexual
you know
try to tell
I tried to tell these these panelists
that we've moved up to 10 o'clock and
they're just making these discussing
sexual jokes cat
um but uh but the Pervert over here
makes a good point
Weiss was behind that rejected plea deal
that basically gave immunity to Future
crimes to uh to Hunter so there's
something fishy in fishville what is it
Greg no one is above the law all right
let's do it
say that all the time
usually about people who are Totally
Above the Law yes exactly
people say that I hear that every day
for something that is so just like not
at all accurate tons of people are above
the law yeah and most of them are in our
government right usually if you're if
you're a cog in the system then you're
not going to face the same penalties
under that exact same system that you're
a part of yes so it's like I think a lot
of us feel a little disillusioned by it
I think a lot of us aren't expecting
much you see this stuff come out you're
like all right well we'll see I'll
believe it when I see it that's
something will actually happen you know
I feel bad for you because I am above
the law
[Laughter]
are you Above the Law David with that
haircut
ah
my haircut's awesome Greg yeah I don't
know again
I didn't even get out of jail but it
didn't even move
gonna like like dance in the wind but
it's stuck there man uh do you have any
information that you can share with us
on this Hunter Biden inquiry
well it's a total sham I mean there's no
ambiguity about it this guy is a hack
yeah Weiss yeah he did this he worked
with the defense team to come up with
this hatch-up plan they try to pull one
over on a judge and they happen to get
the one judge in DC who's not also a
hack right it was like hey wait a minute
isn't this plea deal a little over the
top and then they had to scramble and
say oh forget it so then he also could
have asked to be a special counsel
earlier he didn't do that so what's
changed well now he has to it's a
cover-up now we're in cover-up mode so
this will take us to pass the election
because it's going to be you know oh two
years you know it always takes forever
to do these investigations they have
everything already but you know they got
to cross all the t's done all the eyes
and
make all the excuses so the whole thing
is uh is the Sham it's a sham it's a
shame and that was a great informative
but joke joke free analysis
thank you that's true that's true
I'm going to move on to uh
uh say what he said but funnier
good luck good luck I don't even
remember what you said that's that's the
impact I have on the discourse I kind of
like Merrick Garland the Aegean
announcing all of this you're the ages
like hip son passive nature well you
know David Weiss asked me to be the
special counsel yeah and then he took no
questions so just very you know nothing
to see here very passive yeah all right
up next California prosecutors will not
press charges against the 7-Eleven
employees who went viral defending
themselves with a stick
thank you
shout out to the audience your applauds
beat
your audience after my heart uh the
robbery suspect who's since been
arrested after cops learned he was
connected to multiple robberies what a
surprise you mean thieves actually Rob
more than one place
do you mean recidivism actually exists I
had no idea
you can hear it cat right now you can
hear the left going oh my God this is
going to the green light vigilantism and
people are going to start having their
own Frontier Justice
yeah I think that's why in the first
place they protect they said okay we're
going to investigate this when I don't
really know how long the investigation
they kind of just pretended to be
investigating because the whole thing is
on video yeah and like this guy wasn't
just stealing but he was saying he was
going to shoot these people yeah so I
feel like that is where you kind of have
to draw the line and if that's a
boundary of mine personally is it yeah
when someone says I'm gonna shoot and
kill you then like I'm that's when it's
over you should light you should lighten
up a bit yeah
you know it's just words Lauren this is
this is great news this is great news
could you imagine I'm actually
encouraged by it yeah me too I'm
encouraged I'm encouraged that if you
can actually protect yourself in
California no charges no charges we're
pressed against the the owners of this
7-Eleven in California
7-Eleven's now gonna start selling
sticks
when we when I first
when I first saw this story my like a
week ago the video I was like oh no
those poor guys they're gonna press
charges against them for defending
themselves and their store from being
robbed for a third time and that didn't
happen it didn't happen stopped it it's
the third time and they're right across
the street from the police department
and by the way they called the police to
previous occasions and they just
couldn't get there fast enough when the
guy left I didn't know that right across
the street we're very I always thought
about living across the street from the
cops
you ever think about that like being
close to stupid stuff like ah it'd be
great to be next to a hospital well it
is I did that once and then you get the
sirens yeah you do you do you know but
it's like if anything happens just walk
over there yeah that's what's great I
like to be a regular at the hospital me
too no it's like hey Greg what's going
on and I'll just sit there with a cup of
coffee in the corner drinking it like um
Norm from cheers exactly but uh I I um
are you gonna go out and now that you
now this is gonna make it easier for you
to just beat up people right because you
love beating the crap out of people with
sticks this is a victory for people like
you it is true the older I get Greg the
more
or I just want to unload on someone with
a bamboo pole that happens to be in my
where did he even get that now it's a
piece of bamboo that roof was a bamboo
what is it 7-Eleven I mean it's like
I feel like more people have per per
square foot more people have been died
have died or been injured in 7-Eleven
than in Vietnam during the 1970s so much
you do research on that because it's
like how many how many videos and things
have you seen in 7-Eleven and compare
that to like war footage
per square footage per square footage
yeah it's the deadliest place on Earth
exactly
especially if you're gonna have one of
those microwave hot dogs
Slurpee Heaven yeah don't knock them
those are delicious
they're as good as the Amtrak you uh
what do you what do you make so first of
all you know I think that you deserve
credit for this I think you you were on
the front lines of this and cheered on
uh the uh stick wielders yes and stood
up for them no one else would
I realized I realized you had to DARE
them to get arrested like you're like
okay I dare you to arrest these people
because if you do you're gonna make them
into Heroes and they knew that because
they watched this show the number one
show yeah
great
you know what they did the prosecutors
saw your segment of 7-Eleven and they
took a big gulp
[Applause]
so he's so stupid I want to punch him
up next we're giving good advice because
we're all super nice
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else